mein name ist gesine lötzsch ich bin
seit 2002 direkt gewählte abgeordnete
hier über den lichtenberg im wahlkreis
die hochburg der linken liegt in der
hauptstadt im bundestagswahlkreis berlin
lichtenberg hat die partei vor vier
jahren 29,3 prozent der zweitstimmen
erhalten
bei den erststimmen war es noch
deutlicher 34,8 prozent gingen an gesine
lötzsch wie sind sie zur politik
gekommen
ja ich bin in den wendezeiten quasi in
die politik gekommen und zwar war für
mich ausschlaggebend die wahl im märz
1990 alle waren ja davon überzeugt die
spd gewinnt und dann war es die so
genannte allianz für deutschland und da
dachte ich jetzt gehst du mal und meldet
sich bei der damals pds und sagt hier
würde ich gerne mitmachen was macht
lichtenberg außenbezirk von sehr großer
vielfalt mit sehr interessanten
architektonischen kleinode wie zum
beispiel das mit van der rohe haus und
es ist der zumindest ostbezirk der die
größte nationale vielfalt hat das leben
hier sehr viele menschen die aus vietnam
stammen und sehr viele menschen die aus
der ehemaligen sowjetunion stammen aber
auch eine große anzahl von polen und
polen
und gerade hinter uns gibt es auch als
internationale studentenwohnheim also
ein sehr vielfältiger bezogen welche
herausforderungen gibt es
die grössten herausforderungen sind
überall in den großstädten die fragen
des wohnens stemmten
hier sind wir in einem gebiet wo es noch
sehr viele genossenschaftswohnungen gibt
ich habe das große glück auch in einer
genossenschaftswohnung zu leben
aber wenn sich die familie vergrößert
eine größere wohnung gebraucht wird das
ist sehr sehr kompliziert und wir haben
im bezirk eine sehr große
unterschiedlichkeit also hier im süden
des bezirks stichwort regensburger burg
karlshorst sind die einkommen höher im
norden hohenschönhausen ort ist es
komplizierter da fehlen zum beispiel
sehr viele ärztinnen und ärzte und
gerade die gesundheitliche versorgung
die versorgung mit fachärzten und
fraglos ein großes thema
wie wollen sie regieren also erstmal
sehr wichtig dass jede partei im
wahlkampf deutlich machen wofür sie
steht da steht bei uns an allererster
stelle die frage der sozialen
gerechtigkeit die frage einer
friedlichen außenpolitik und wichtig ist
weiterhin für mich bei der entscheidung
ob man in einer regierung geht oder
nicht ob man etwas erreichen oder
durchsetzen können die fdp zum beispiel
war ja jetzt nicht in den letzten jahren
aber davor viele jahre auch mit wenigen
prozent an der bundesregierung beteiligt
und hat ja nie gesagt auch wir sind so
klein wir können nicht durchsetzen also
das wäre für mich das kriterium dass
hier die sozialen fragen in fragen der
friedlichen außenpolitik wirklich
wirkungsvoll etwas ändern können
ansonsten muss wenn ich in der regierung
ist die linke kompromissbereit
also ich glaube dass ja die
herausforderung ist wenn man mit anderen
zusammenarbeiten will das so zu
gestalten dass sich niemand verbieten
muss und wir sehen ja jetzt gerade in
den diskussionen der vergangenen wochen
das ist ja ich sag mal plötzlich will
herr habe waffen in krisengebiete
verkaufen dass alle parteien natürlich
auch interne diskussion führen müssen
aber erfolgreich kann man nur zusammen
regieren und das ist jetzt mal schön im
türen auch der ansatz von bodo ramelow
werde nicht der eine dem anderen nur zu
sagen
zeigen wir ich bin hier der stärkere
sondern dass man wirklich gemeinsame
ziele formuliert und da haben wir
eigentlich in berlin jetzt in der
legislaturperiode auf der landesebene
ist schon gewissen zeitpunkt jetzt guckt
ja da war es schon eigentlich ganz gute
erfahrungen macht das die liebe auch
sehr deutlich ihre position auch in die
öffentlichkeit getragen hat und nicht
gesagt hat dass koalitionsfrieden ist
wichtiger